Hey, Youtube!
I’m SCP Explained, and this is… also SCP
Explained.
Before we get into today’s story, go ahead
and smash that like button and ring the bell
to be notified every time one of our epic
videos hits your subscription feed.
And don’t forget to share this video with
everyone you know - friends, family members,
pets, and even that sweaty guy at the bus
stop.
Alright, that’s more than enough pandering
to the algorithm for one video… or is it?
Because today we’ll be talking about another
one of Dr. Bright’s many misadventures.
For those of you who don’t know - and if
you don’t, I’m wondering why you clicked
on this video - Dr. Jack Bright is one of
the most chaotic and unpredictable researchers
working at the Foundation.
His status as an immortal consciousness means
that even his most hair-brained schemes rarely
have lasting consequences for the man himself.
The same cannot be said about the amount of
collateral damage those same schemes cause,
mind you.
And quite recently, Dr. Bright decided to
attempt one of the most dangerous and immoral
acts that a human being - or humanoid anomaly
- is capable of.
That’s right!
Dr. Bright has started a Youtube channel.
I know.
I should have given a fair warning before
saying something so alarming, but sadly, it
is true.
And much like every time Dr. Bright gets an
idea like this into his crazy little head,
the rest of us just have to watch and wait
for the inevitable backfire to play itself
out.
So sit back and enjoy the show as Dr. Bright
becomes the aspiring YouTuber, Mr. Bright.
The first video on Mr. Bright’s channel
is a short audio-visual remix simply titled
“Clef Music.”
It begins with Jack Bright sneaking up behind
fellow researcher and occasionally respected
colleague Dr. Alto Clef with a pepperoni pizza
in hand.
Dr. Clef appears to be totally unaware of
Bright’s approach, and is utterly shocked
when Bright smears the entire pizza - cheese,
toppings, sauce, and all across his face.
The rest of the video is recording of Clef’s
angered reaction, set to electronic dance
music with certain phrases enhanced through
the use of autotune.
The top comment from user NotKondraki reads
“Oh, I get it!
His name is Alto Clef, and he’s singing.
XD”
There’s a reply to that same comment from
user 3ManyGuns that says, “JACK.
DELETE THIS.”
in all caps.
The video received around one thousand views
over three days, which wasn’t much by the
standards of most well-known YouTubers, but
it was more than enough encouragement for
Mr. Bright to keep the content train a-movin.
But what to do next?
After all, autotune remixes hadn’t been
at the peak of their popularity in almost
a decade.
Prank videos had also evolved to a level of
elaborate absurdity that far surpassed the
novelty of a pie to the face.
Mr. Bright would have to get creative if he
wanted to remain even somewhat relevant in
the ever-evolving Youtube algorithm.
He eventually decided to release a vlog series
titled “My Life In Site 19”, during which
Bright would film his daily routine in one
of the most secure Foundation containment
sites in existence.
Needless to say, the 05 council had the first
video in the series taken down almost immediately
via Youtube's copyright strike system.
A breach of classified information like that
couldn’t be allowed to be freely accessed
on the internet, even if the total views on
the video at the time of the takedown had
barely cracked three hundred.
Jack realized his channel was going nowhere
fast, as only had around ten subscribers,
and most of them were members of the research
team that he had personally told to subscribe.
He had to find a way to bring the numbers
up without getting in further trouble with
the 05 council.
That’s when it hit him!
He’d conceal his identity with some kind
of cartoon avatar - or, as they were sometimes
known in the YouTube world: a rantsona.
Maybe something that sorta looked like him,
but was abstract enough that nobody would
know there were any ties between his channel
and The Foundation.
So he drew up a few sketches and eventually
settled on a design for his rantsona that
captured his personality and could be placed
on screen whenever he didn’t want to appear
on camera.
It was an unfortunate wake-up call when Mr.
Bright found out that not only were caucasian
men with brown hair far from uncommon in the
world of Youtuber rantsonas, a fair amount
of them also sported glasses.
There was at least one other rantsona that
wore a lab coat just like his own.
Before long, Mr. Bright was receiving a ton
of comments comparing him to these other creators,
saying that he was both a rip-off and a trend
chaser.
Mr. Bright couldn’t believe it.
All that work to fit in among the rantsonas,
only to wind up being called generic.
But he was nothing if not resourceful, and
the researcher turned Youtuber realized he
could use this turn of events to his advantage.
He released his next video, titled “Why
I’m Leaving This Community.”
While he never specified what community he
was leaving, or any specific grievance towards
another Youtuber, Mr. Bright did spend a lot
of time talking about the Youtube terms of
service and how making the like-to-dislike
bar invisible was causing him undue stress
that had required him to distance himself
from making videos for a while.
He ended the video by firmly stating enough
was enough and that he wouldn’t take it
anymore - again, never specifying what “it”
was.
The video got seventeen thousand views in
the first two days since its upload, and the
comments were filled with users applauding
Mr. Bright for his bravery and apparent ability
to speak his mind.
Overnight his subscribers grew to five hundred,
and countless comments continued to pour in
showing support for the nebulous cause that
Mr. Bright now stood for.
Now, this was the response Mr. Bright had
been looking for, and he planned to grow his
audience even further by playing into the
vague anti-establishment angle that his previous
video had suggested.
He appeared in front of the camera himself
in the video “Youtube Doesn’t Want You
To See This”, this time eschewing all foundation
apparel and filming against a green-screened
background of an absurdly large kitchen with
spotless white cabinets.
The kitchen was, of course, a computer-generated
image Mr. Bright had devised to show that
he was successful and wealthy but also casual
and down to earth.
Over the course of the video, Mr. Bright insisted
that some unnamed higher-ups at Youtube were
trying to silence him, and that nearly every
video he made was allegedly being demonetized.
This claim was made, despite the fact that
Mr. Bright was actually not yet able to become
a member of Youtube's partner program because
he hadn’t met the subscriber threshold to
start earning ad revenue.
Still, he was sure that centering himself
in a controversy would be a surefire way to
gain more subscribers.
However, he was proven very wrong.
Within hours of the video's release, the commenters
were tearing Mr. Bright apart, calling him
a liar and a fake.
Like a pack of tiny amateur detectives, Mr.
Bright’s audience turned on him, and his
reputation began to turn sour.
Response videos came out later in the week,
bashing Mr. Bright Youtube channel and accusing
him - rightfully so - of spreading misinformation.
This was perhaps the biggest setback yet.
Though the channel had grown a bit as he had
hoped, the small fanbase surrounding it had
turned incredibly defensive.
Every comment section on a video talking about
Mr. Bright was a war zone between self-proclaimed
Bright stans and anyone unlucky enough to
anger them.
The worst part was, Mr. Bright himself had
no idea what the arguments were even about
at this point.
He wasn’t sure what he said or did that
had caused such a polarized reaction.
He tried to win the audience back with a few
more Dr. Clef prank videos, but it was no
use.
Clef had gotten wise to Bright’s youtube
plans, and whenever he was on screen, he would
speak with so much profanity that the audio
would become basically unusable without being
censored.
Additionally, he would fire several of his
guns into the air in a wild and dangerous
fashion.
These factors meant that Jack had to shelve
pretty much every video involving Clef, and
the ones that he was able to edit all of the
swears and gunshots out of wear borderline
incomprehensible.
It was clear enough that the Mr. Bright brand
was on its way out, and Dr. Bright had to
make peace with that.
He had essentially three options available
to him:
Rebrand and hope that the previous audience
forgets about the controversy surrounding
the channel.
Start an entirely new Youtube channel as if
nothing had ever happened or…
Give up on being a Youtuber entirely.
Option number 3 certainly wasn’t going to
happen, and to commit to option 2 would mean
losing the subscribers and views he had already
gained, so really only the prospect of a total
rebrand could make any of this seemingly futile
struggle worthwhile.
It had to be option one.
In order for this to work, Dr. Bright had
to choose a new form of content that was so
low effort that he couldn’t possibly be
perceived as bad at it.
He had been watching a number of Youtube videos
for research, and eventually, he decided that
reaction content was the ideal way to make
a bunch of videos without having to spend
too much time on each individual one.
All he had to do was wait for other creators
to make the content, and he would record his
unscripted reactions.
He could potentially do this all day, provided
he continued to supply himself with other
youtube videos.
Of course, there was a slight issue of how
he would have to present himself in these
videos.
His face was already somewhat known in the
community at large, and his now all but discarded
rantsona would cause similar problems.
Then, Dr. Bright was struck with another epiphany.
During a late-night session of obsessive content
research, which had regretfully been taking
the place of the actual SCP research he was
supposed to be doing, Dr. Bright fell asleep
on his desk with the autoplay feature on.
He awoke several hours later to hear the sounds
of a virtual youtuber - or Vtuber - reacting
to content the same way he was hoping to on
his channel.
A vtuber rig!
Of course!
Dr. Bright thought to himself.
The answer had been right in front of him!
By rigging his body movements to a 3D animated
character, he would both have a baseline level
of anonymity and the capacity to realistically
translate his reactions into the digital realm.
This was genius!
His channel would soar in popularity once
he created an appealing virtual character
to embody himself.
Goodbye, Mr. Bright, and hello - Vtuber Bright!
But of course, he had to design the avatar
himself, acquire the correct software, and
learn how to utilize all of it before stepping
once again into a world of comparisons to
similar content.
On second thought, this was not going to be
anywhere near as easy as Dr. Bright initially
thought it would be.
Perhaps there was no easy to get views on
Youtube, and obtaining positive success and
notoriety on the platform wasn’t something
that had a simple clear-cut answer.
Maybe this latest venture had taught Dr. Bright
that being himself and focusing on his work
was…
Nah, he didn’t learn anything like that.
He just decided to take a big shortcut through
all the real hard work that goes into becoming
a vtuber.
Because when Dr. Bright is faced with a problem
that can’t be overcome through non-anomalous
means, he finds the right SCP for the job
and solves it the supposedly easy way.
With the “supposedly” doing a lot of heavy
lifting in that sentence.
In the case of his current vtuber aspirations,
Dr. Bright enlisted the help of SCP-1471 - Ma10.
The skull-faced SCP already dwelled inside
of virtual space, and though it was perhaps
just a coincidence based on the specific vtuber
Dr. Bright had stumbled upon: it seemed that
humanoid wolves had been proven to be quite
popular with the typical vtuber audience.
Besides, Dr. Bright wasn’t unaware of the,
ahem, sort of people who were always eager
to join SCP-1471’s fan club, er… research
team.
With only a few minor modifications to its
programming, Ma10 was able to perform all
the essential functions of a Vtuber rig.
Dr. Bright would move his arms or head in
meatspace, and Ma10 would mimic the movement
like it was some kind of shared game between
the two.
Since SCP-1471 didn’t have a voice of its
own, Dr. Bright provided a very spirited vocal
performance through his own microphone.
After a few test runs, the dynamic duo of
SCP and researcher had succeeded in becoming
one complete vtuber.
His initial plan to become a popular and well-respected
Youtuber may have failed, and the original
channel name of Mr. Bright soon faded from
the internet’s collective memory, but Dr.
Bright’s determination to keep on grinding
and adapt to new forms of content was something
that any up-and-coming creator could find
inspiring.
That is, unless they too had let countless
hours of important research on dangerous anomalies
fall to the wayside in pursuit of internet
fame.
If that is the case, maybe what is best for
some would-be YouTubers not to leave their
day job so soon - especially not when the
lives of millions hang in the balance.
Now go check out “SCP-963 What Would You
Do If You Were Immortal Like Dr. Jack Bright?”
and “Can Dr Bright Defeat Billionaire Jeff
Bezos?”
for more classic Dr. Bright adventures!